Otto Skorzeny, henchman, assassin, commando,
spy, double-agent, mercenary.
What was the truth about him?
You asked for him like a million times, you
got him.
Roll title!
The Most Dangerous Man in Vienna
Otto Skorzeny was born into a middle-class
family in Vienna, Austria, on June 12, 1908.
As a student he distinguished himself in scientific
topics, and after graduating he enlisted at
the University of Vienna as an engineering
student.
His great passion was fencing.
He joined the University fencing team and
during a match he received the prominent scar
on his cheek, known in German as a ‘Schmiss’
which was then a coveted mark of bravery among
German and Austrian youth.
In 1931, as Nazism was gaining popularity
in Europe, Skorzeny joined the Austrian Nazi
Party, filling the ranks of the local version
of the paramilitary SA Brownshirts.
Clever, ambitious and physically imposing
at 6 ft 4 [1.93 Metres] he must have been
a valued member.
In the meanwhile he had earned his degree
and had started working as a civil engineer.
The Most Dangerous Man in Berlin
Austria had become part of Germany with the
1938 Anschluss.
So, when World War II broke out in 1939, Skorzeny
applied to join the Wehrmacht.
But his military career got off to a bumpy
start when his application to join the Luftwaffe
was denied.
He was told he was too tall and too old at
the age of 31.
Instead, he joined the SS and became an officer-cadet
in the Liebstandarte, Hitler’s bodyguard
regiment.
In 1940, Skorzeny was a second lieutenant
in the Waffen-SS.
His engineering skills proved useful when
he designed special ramps to load tanks onto
ships.
But he also proved his courage under fire
during combat in Holland, France, and the
Balkans.
Here he was decorated after capturing a large
Yugoslav force, and was promoted to first
lieutenant.
Skorzeny was then transferred to the Eastern
Front after the launch of Operation Barbarossa
in June 1941, with the 2nd SS Panzer Division
“Das Reich”.
He was part of the unsuccessful siege of Moscow
and in December 1942, now a captain, received
a head wound from a piece of shrapnel.
Skorzeny was awarded the Iron Cross for bravery,
and then sent home to Vienna to recuperate.
While there, he became fascinated by the idea
of commando operations and read all the books
he could find about them.
He then transformed those ideas into plans
for unconventional warfare, which he submitted
to higher headquarters.
And they started to take notice.
His concepts soon reached the desk of Ernst
Kaltenbrunner, the new head of the Reich security
services and successor to Reinhard Heydrich.
Skorzeny’s ideas were passed on to General
Schellenberg, head of the SS foreign intelligence
service.
Skorzeny and Schellenberg met and the General
was so impressed that he appointed him as
commander of the newly created Waffen Sonderverband
z.b.V.
Friedenthal, an SS unit dedicated to special
operations.
His career as a commando leader had just begun.
The Most Dangerous Man on a Glider
Skorzeny and his unit launched into their
first mission in the summer of 1943: Operation
François.
The plan was to organize the nomadic Qashqai
people, in Iran, into an armed guerrilla force
which could serve the German war effort.
Skorzeny’s paratroopers were also assigned
to disrupt the supply lines between the Allies
and the Soviets and to turn the local population
against the Allied presence.
Skorzeny parachuted into Northern Iran packed
with gold and explosives.
His intention was to bribe the tribesmen elders
and win their support for the mobilization
of the entire people.
The operation proved to be a failure: a fellow
agent, Paul Ernst Fackenheim, made a remark
that as soon as they were out of gold, the
Persians sold them to the British.
Skorzeny’s next mission would prove his
most famous and spectacular success: Operation
Oak, the rescue of Benito Mussolini, imprisoned
after the Monarchist coup in July 1943.
First Skorzeny had to find Mussolini.
The ex-dictator was continually moved from
one hiding place to another, but the Germans
discovered him at a villa on the isle of La
Maddalena, near Sardinia.
Skorzeny then flew over in a Heinkel He-111
bomber to take aerial photos of the location,
but the plane was shot down by Allied fighters
and crashed into the sea.
Skorzeny and his men were rescued by an Italian
warship.
Mussolini was moved again and the chase continued.
Finally, Skorzeny tracked him down to the
Campo Imperatore Hotel, a remote and fortified
resort on the Gran Sasso mountain in central
Italy.
The hotel was accessible only by funicular.
He, Luftwaffe General Kurt Student and Major
Otto-Harald Mors, a paratrooper battalion
commander, came up with a workable plan.
Skorzeny assembled a team of 107 commandos
who would be landed in gliders.
On the 12th of September 1943 the gliders
approached the hotel.
Skorzeny realised too late that what he thought
to be a patch of grass was a rocky incline.
His glider almost crashed, but he made it
out in one piece.
Twelve minutes later, Skorzeny had found Mussolini
and not one person had been killed.
The Fuhrer, delighted with Skorzeny, awarded
him the Knights Cross.
As a result, he became Hitler’s favourite
commando and was dubbed “the most dangerous
man in Europe” by the Allies … although
propaganda chief Dr Goebbels may have been
the first to give him that title.
Propaganda coverage of the event however hid
the fact that most of the planning and execution
had to be credited to Skorzeny’s associates,
General Student and Major Mors.
Skorzeny stole their thunder by making sure
he would be the one escorting Mussolini to
the get-away plane in full view of the cameras.
Skorzeny though should be recognised with
the stroke of genius that ensured the raid
was bloodless.
He had secured the cooperation of General
Soleti of the Carabinieri, the military police.
Soleti was actually the first one to approach
the Hotel and ordered the heavily armed military
policemen to stand down.
It should be noted that footage and photos
of the event show many of the Italian guards
posing with big smiles by Mussolini and Skorzeny,
hinting at their true loyalties.
Based on testimonies from one of the guards,
Mussolini seemed to be the least happy to
have been rescued …
The next mission for Skorzeny was Operation
Long Jump, November 1943.
Its ambitious goal was to kill or kidnap the
Allies’ “Big Three” leaders - Stalin,
Churchill, Roosevelt—at their strategic
conference in Tehran, Iran.
A first group of six German operatives landed
in Qom, before proceeding to Teheran on camel
back.
Skorzeny was supposed to join the group with
a second team of assassins.
Unfortunately for them, a few months earlier,
the Operation’s planner SS officer von Ortel
had just made friends with a Wehrmacht Lieutenant
in a bar in Copenhagen.
Blind drunk, Ortel had spilled the beans on
Long Jump.
That lieutenant, well he was a Soviet intelligence
officer in disguise.
Roosevelt and Churchill were alerted to the
plot and were kept safe at the Soviet Embassy.
The NKVD then seized the six German commandos
and forced them to radio to Skorzeny's team
that the operation had failed.
To give the full picture, some sources claim
that this plot never existed.
It was just a clever ruse of Stalin and/or
the NKVD to force the Western leaders to stay
inside the Soviet Embassy, where their conversations
could be easily bugged.
The next high level hit commissioned to Skorzeny
was the capture of Tito, Operation Knight’s
Leap.
Also in this case Skorzeny and his commandos
attacked by gliders, while conventional forces
engaged Tito’s partisans around his mountain
helicopters.
Did I say helicopters?
Sorry, I meant headquarters.
In any case, the partisans’ resistance was
fierce, stalling the pincer movement and allowing
Tito to escape.
Skorzeny would finally have time to shine
after the 20th of July 1944, following the
attempted bombing on Hitler.
In his memoir, he claimed he played an integral
part in restoring order to Berlin, where the
conspirators had initiated plan ‘Valkyrie’
to topple the regime.
Skorzeny infiltrated the conspirators’ base
of operations and had the “Valkyrie” order
rescinded.
This was an order intended to quell a possible
coup, but had been cleverly exploited by the
conspirators to trick German troops into arresting
loyal Nazi officials.
Skorzeny’s actions contributed to dissipate
confusion, restore communications to Fuhrer
Headquarters and preventing a possible civil
war between German troops.
Skorzeny took charge of Wehrmacht administration
until normalcy returned.
Again, Hitler was delighted.
In October 1944 he dispatched him to Budapest
to lead Operation Panzerfaust, aka Operation
Mickey Mouse.
The Fuehrer was not pleased with Hungarian
leader Admiral Horthy, an uneasy ally against
the Soviet Union, who was actually pro-American
and had always refused to deport the Jewish
population.
The Germans got wind that he was negotiating
with the allies and Skorzeny was sent to exact
punishment.
Skorzeny and his commandos stormed the presidential
palace, seized the Admiral’s son, rolled
him into a carpet and kidnapped him.
Horthy was forced to negotiate, and eventually
to stand down.
His leadership was replaced by a puppet government
under the Arrow Cross party, staunchly anti-Semitic.
During the following 56 days, an estimated
320,000 Hungarian Jews were sent to their
deaths in the gas chambers.
Another 100,000 starved or died of disease.
In December of 1944 Skorzeny launched his
most infamous mission: Operation Greif, or
‘Griffin’.
The goal was to capture key bridges over the
Meuse river during the Battle of the Bulge,
the last German offensive in the West.
Skorzeny’s plan was ingenious: he selected
commandos who were fluent in English, dressed
them in American uniforms and sent them behind
enemy lines in Belgium to spread panic and
confusion.
Skorzeny’s men cut communication wires,
issued fake orders, and turned around road
signs.
The Americans grew paranoid: some GIs fired
on each other, while others grilled their
mates about American popular culture to identify
if they were German agents.
If you were American, but did not care about
baseball nor movie stars, you could get arrested!
At one point, Field Marshal Bernard Montgomery
refused to show his ID and had his car tires
shot out.
He was then dragged into a barn and restrained
until his identity could be confirmed.
Skorzeny spread the false rumour among his
men that the real aim was the assassination
of General Eisenhower, headquartered in Paris.
German agents captured by the Americans, confessed
to this plot.
As a result, Eisenhower was put under virtual
arrest for his own protection.
Griffin eventually failed and many Germans
were easily identified and shot as spies.
As the Reich crumbled, Skorzeny’s final
involvement was with Operation Werewolf.
This was a resistance movement, mostly composed
of Hitler Youth members, trained in guerrilla
tactics to oppose an Allied occupation.
It actually was a desperate propaganda ruse
by Goebbels to raise morale.
But Skorzeny hijacked the plan and used this
small force to aid the escaping Nazi high
officials.
The Soviet NKVD, probably overestimating the
size and importance of Werewolf, killed roughly
5,000 boys, aged 15 to 17, for suspected guerrilla
activity.
A few days after Hitler’s suicide, Skorzeny
handed himself over to the Americans.
He was a highly decorated, well-respected
military professional but his directive for
his men to wear American uniforms got him
in trouble.
This was considered a war crime and was put
on trial in 1947.
Luckily for him, he escaped execution when
British SOE operatives confirmed they wore
German uniforms during the war.
But he had to answer from other charges.
Before he could be prosecuted, though, Skorzeny
escaped from the POW camp with the help of
two ex-SS men, dressed as American military
police.
He later claimed this was a plan of the OSS,
the CIA’s predecessor: his freedom, in return
for his services.
Was this true?
The Most Dangerous Man in Madrid
Skorzeny first hid in Bavaria, then Salzburg
and finally Spain, where he cooperated with
Francisco Franco’s military and intelligence
services.
He was “de-Nazified” in absentia by a
German court in 1952 but was still a “person
of interest” for the famed Austrian Nazi
hunter, Simon Wiesenthal.
In any case, he could lead an open life.
He had a young wife, Ilse von Finckenstein.
He had several legitimate activities: an engineering
firm, an import-export business … and a
mercenary security company.
But he apparently had time for other endeavours.
He founded a Neo-Nazi group called CEDADE,
the Spanish Circle of Friends of Europe and
is rumoured to have smuggled ex-Nazis to South
America.
Particularly in Argentina, where he served
briefly as military advisor to Juan Perón.
Most notably he was bodyguard to Evita.
There are even rumours of an affair between
the two.
I wonder who may have spread them …
In the late 50s he became fixated with gaining
entry to the UK.
This may be the reason why in 1959 Otto Skorzeny
bought a farm in County Kildare, Ireland.
He was granted temporary visas to stay in
Ireland, but state records mention his indignation
at the continual refusal of the British authorities
to allow him entry in the UK.
Newspaper reports in the 1960s give another
version: his farm in Ireland was a place where
fleeing Nazis could hide, but no evidence
was found to substantiate this claim.
Maybe he just liked the Guinness?
The Most Dangerous Man in Tel Aviv
And now for something truly puzzling.
As an escaped former SS, who had indirectly
contributed to the deportation of the Hungarian
Jews, Skorzeny knew very well that his name
was top in the list of Nazi hunter Simon Wiesenthal.
And so, he was the first one to be surprised
when agents of the Mossad, Israeli intelligence,
came to recruit him …
Early 1962.
Skorzeny was having some drinks at a bar in
Madrid with his wife Ilse.
The two befriended another younger couple
of German tourists, who had just been robbed
and were looking for some help.
The two couples went on drinking and, apparently,
flirting, until the Skorzenys invited them
to their villa.
Just when things seemed to, well … kick
off … well they did kick off, but in another
way.
Skorzeny pulled a gun on the couple:
“I know who you are, and I know why you
are here.
You are Mossad, and you’ve come here to
kill me!”
The man replied
“If we had come to kill you, you would have
been dead weeks ago.”
The two operatives were there to offer Skorzeny
a deal: they needed his services and would
pay handsomely.
Skorzeny’s was not interested in money.
What he wanted, was to be removed from Wiesenthal’s
list.
The Mossad agents agreed.
Skorzeny was flown to Tel Aviv, where he met
Mossad agent Joe Ranaan.
He was also Viennese, but as a Jew, he had
lost all his family in the camps.
Ranaan took the ex-SS to the Yad Vashem, the
Holocaust Museum, and observed that he appeared
respectful.
Skorzeny’s mission was to thwart Egypt’s
military rocket programme, led by Heinz Krug,
a German scientist formerly associated with
Werner Von Braun.
The Austrian commando was shown a letter from
Wiesenthal, accepting the removal of his name
from the list of Nazi criminals.
In truth, Wiesenthal had refused.
The letter was a Mossad forgery.
Skorzeny kept his promise and he delivered,
big time.
He flew to Egypt and identified all German
scientists working for the programme.
He then unmasked several companies around
Europe that were secretly selling rocket components
to the Egyptians.
He even carried out a campaign of intimidation
against the scientists and mailed explosive
packages prepared by the Mossad, killing five
Egyptian technicians.
One day in 1962, while in Madrid, Skorzeny
received a phone call.
It was Heinz Krug, the lead scientist of the
programme.
Krug was dead scared and was seeking Skorzeny’s
help and protection.
Skorzeny arranged to meet him in Munich.
As he drove him out of town in a white Mercedes
he reassured him: he had already hired some
bodyguards and they were driving to meet them.
As they stepped out of the car and into the
woods, Skorzeny shot Krug.
Three Mossad agents then took care of the
body by dissolving it in acid.
Skorzeny’s job was done.
He had not made a penny out of it.
He didn’t know it but was still on Wiesenthal
list.
But at least he would be spared by the Mossad.
The Most Dangerous Man in a FOIA Search Engine
Another intelligence service famously associated
with Otto Skorzeny was the CIA.
We wanted to verify this claim directly at
the source and so we did some rummaging in
the CIA’s own Freedom Of Information Act
(FOIA) search engine.
A brief memo states that in 1961 Skorzeny
had a plan to kidnap Fidel Castro.
This plan had the approval of CIA Director
Allen Dulles, but had been vetoed by JFK.
There is a catch: the memo quotes an interview
released by Skorzeny to a Peruvian newspaper
in 1966.
Knowing the man’s knack for self-publicity,
can we truly believe this?
So, we dug deeper.
On the 26th of January 1951 a report was sent
to the Secretary of State from Germany by
John J. McCloy, American High Commissioner
for Occupied Germany.
McCloy reports that Chancellor Adenauer was
worried about rumours of Skorzeny training
the Spanish military with US covert support.
McCloy was not aware of this scheme and admitted
it was worrying.
The CIA knew very well that Skorzeny was in
Spain.
They learned this from a letter dated 21st
of September 1949, sent by FBI Director J.
Edgar Hoover.
Skorzeny had been sighted
“working in Spain with a group of Nazis
with the blessings of Franco”.
In April 1951, the CIA was keeping tabs on
Skorzeny’s activities in Madrid.
In particular, they wrote about internal feuding
amongst former Nazi officers, with concerns
for it to go public.
The memo reads:
“View possibility unfavourable publicity
break as result Skorzeny’s manoeuvring.
Consider important we clarify our interests
and any US connections fully.
Can you explain claims Skorzeny connected
with or supported by US Colonel Thompson or
Stimpson.
View categorical denial”
The agent asks the question: is possibly the
CIC, Counter-Intelligence Corps behind Skorzeny?
The CIC was a Cold War era secret service
within the US Army ranks.
Moving to the 1960s, the CIA kept a close
eye on Skorzeny’s relationship to ‘UPHILL’
which appears to be a code name for an organisation.
One report states that the Chief of Uphill
had warned that US support for Skorzeny would
be a source of embarrassment for the White
House.
This is similar to Adenauer’s warning.
The picture that emerges so far is that some
US agency, possibly the CIC, had some form
of contact with him, and German authorities
had warned the US to be careful about it.
But what of Skorzeny’s relationship with
other powers?
There is another document that complicates
matters even more.
The agent signs himself as ‘Heckenschuetze’
- ‘sniper’.
We’ll post the link in the description,
so you can read it in full, but here is the
gist of it.
At the end of 1943, sensing that the War would
be lost, Martin Bormann, Hitler’s secretary,
created a secret organization called
‘HACKE’
It was so exclusive to count only 35 members.
And so secretive that even Himmler was unaware
of it.
The purpose of Hacke was to guarantee the
survival of Nazi officials in case of defeat.
To do so, Hacke racked up half a billion dollars
from concentration camp victims and created
hideouts in Spain, Portugal, Italy, Japan
and Argentina.
But the twist is that the Soviet intelligence
had infiltrated this network, apparently by
blackmailing Bormann, lest they revealed the
existence of Hacke to Himmler.
Hacke remained active after the war, but here
comes anothet twist:
“One of the dark and dangerous KGB figures
in Hacke is the famous
SS Colonel Skorzeny
who presently lives in Madrid and also works
for the Spanish IS (intelligence service).
Skorzeny was under active development by Abakumow
as early as 1942 …
Skorzeny was finally recruited as a collaborator
of Abakumow in the middle of 1944”
Abakumow being a Soviet intelligence General.
His plan was to exploit ex-Nazi officials
and agents settled in the Americas.
The author of the document to be fair states
that it is unclear whether Abakumow succeeded
in his plans, and looks for other clues to
confirm Skorzeny’s allegiance to the KGB.
One of these clues is that Skorzeny was very
close to another ex-Nazi operative, Karl Rudl.
The two had been tasked with a secret mission
by the Vatican (!!!!!) to smuggle a Hungarian
Cardinal out of prison.
Rudl was actually an agent of Abakumow, who
had intentions to hijack the prison escape
to have the Cardinal shot.
Rudl smelled a rat – he was probably going
to get shot, too, while Abakumow would leave
Skorzeny alive.
And so, he aborted the operation.
To recap, from the 1940s to the 1960s Otto
Skorzeny was
A commando for the Nazi security services
A possible double-agent for the Soviets
A member of the neo-Nazi ring ‘HACKE’
An agent of Franco’s intelligence
A hitman for the Mossad
A possible informant to the US CIC
An operative for the Vatican
As you can see, our initial question ‘did
Skorzeny work for the CIA?’
seems irrelevant now.
The answer is probably, no.
If anything, his calendar was too full to
fit them in.
The Most Dangerous Man is no more
In his later years, Otto Skorzeny fell ill
from lung cancer.
On July 5, 1975 he died in Madrid at the age
of 67.
He had two funerals, one in Madrid, and the
other at his family plot in Vienna.
At both, he received full Nazi honours, with
veterans giving him the Nazi salute and singing
some of Hitler’s favourite songs.
Among those present, one man stood apart.
He did not join in with the Nazi nostalgic
paraphernalia, but offered a silent salute
to a fellow secret agent and fighter.
Someone he had grown up hating, but had learned
to respect.
That man was Mossad agent Joe Ranaan.
And it’s with this strange image of an Israeli
spy at a Nazi funeral that we end our story
today.
An image which sums up the career of a man
who had been clearly a follower of Nazi ideology
– but was ultimately loyal only to himself.
I’d like to propose a little game for the
comments section: have a look at the CIA FOIA
Search page, the link is below, and have a
search around, maybe for a famous personality
or event, or even for your own name, why not?
And let us know what you found out!
As usual, thank you for watching.